[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: An award-winning
textile and fashion designer,
a painter, a trained
classical dancer,
a theater artist,
and once a dentist,
our guest today wears
multiple hats, none of which
are visible today, of course.
His life and experiences have
made him a strong advocate
for prevention of child
sexual abuse in India,
and also an inspiration to
many in the LGBTQ community,
including us.
His studio was
recently nominated
for Top 5,000 MSMEs in India,
and the man behind the story
himself, Dr. Ganesh
Nallari, is sure to talk
about his journey of awareness,
self-love, and acceptance.
Please join me in welcoming him.
[APPLAUSE]
GANESH NALLARI: Hello.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
GANESH NALLARI: So the question
always is, where do I begin?
But then-- now when I say
or think of beginning,
I think even the thought of
starting or beginning something
is already a job half done.
So I always believe that
what is most important
is to have the thought and idea,
and how you begin will follow.
So here I am to begin and
share many chapters of my life.
I started my career
as a dentist,
and I practiced for
a couple of years
before I switched onto what
I was more passionate about--
design.
After completing--
even before I started--
even before I studied
dentistry, as a child,
I've always been interested
in art, painting, and dance.
I learned Kuchipudi
for almost 11 years,
and then I switched
to Bharatanatyam.
I learned it for
the longest I could.
So I think what
happened in terms
of why the switch of career--
after finishing
dentistry-- my DDS--
I was trying to--
I was not trying, but I
was preparing for my MDS--
my master's.
And in that process,
I was also working
as a dental lecturer in the same
college where I graduated from,
and they offered me a job.
And I actually took up the job
because I had a crush on one
of my professors.
I thought, oh, I can
see him every day.
That's a secret.
I hope he's watching it now.
But then there was so
much to learn from him.
When I say crush, it's not
purely a physical intimacy,
but everything
about that person,
I just wanted to be like myself.
So I think that's the reason
why I actually took up that job.
Then after a couple of
months, when I was actually
with that professor
of mine, driving down
the NIFT campus in Bangalore, I
just asked him to stop the car
and went to the campus,
picked up the Prospectus,
and then he looked at
me and said, now what?
I said, why not?
And then, the rest is history.
NIFT has been a cakewalk,
because I never really
considered design as something
which I was studying,
but it was something
which was so organic.
It was there within you.
But it's more about
how you polish a skill.
So in fact, until
everybody questioned me
about such a drastic
shift of career
from dentistry to
design, it didn't even
strike me, because it
came so naturally to me.
The only time I had to
actually tell my parents
was before I joined NIFT.
When I told my dad that,
two years of my life,
let me do what I want to.
I'm not going to
blame my parents or--
yeah, I'm not
going to blame them
that they were the ones who
asked me to study dentistry,
but I think I come
from a generation--
I'm talking about
the early '90s,
when everybody was studying
engineering or medicine.
So it was more of
a social pressure.
Though I wanted to do
fine arts, I really
wanted to be a painter.
But I think everybody--
it was understood
that you have to do either
medicine or engineering.
And then-- I wasn't
a bad student.
I said, OK.
Let me just for--
if I have to paint, and I
would still continue painting.
And that's what I did.
Even when I studied
dentistry, in the evenings
I used to paint.
Of course, [? downs ?]
took a break.
[? Downs ?] needs so much more
commitment and time, but even
as a dentist, you need to
have a very good hand skill.
You carve teeth
and wax, you know?
So I scored very well
in all those subjects
where there was a lot of
practical work involved.
So it was never about not being
in touch with your other side.
So NIFT happened and I
think more than anything,
it was about--
you know you never try
to prove to others.
It's more about proving
to your own self.
Of course, there are 100
people watching you--
about all those guys around NIFT
maybe just to hit around women.
You know, how most--
if the most clean-shaved way
of thinking about why people
go to a fashion
institute, because it's
all glamor and the pretty girls.
One, yes.
That was not even
of my interest.
I mean, girls.
And yes, there is glamor
in the fashion industry,
but then there is so much
of hard work as well.
So at NIFT, like I mentioned,
it wasn't about studying,
but it was more
about having fun.
Every time they
gave an assignment,
I would be the first--
I would just like went into
[INAUDIBLE] who was always
trying to finish things much
before my other classmates,
and everybody would look at--
give me those dirty looks,
saying, that-- stop.
Don't show it today.
I'm like, OK, I'll
wait for you all.
Then it was fun.
I eventually got the gold medal.
And that particular year,
I was very fortunate
that I received it from the
president then, Mr. Abdul
Kalam.
So-- and I think at
that point, my dad
was very clear about what
his son wanted to do in life.
After that, there
was no questioning.
He just said, OK.
I remember the day I got
my Best Student award.
I just walked through the crowd
and I said, this is for you.
And I'm sure he--
there was a certain
amount of pride, which--
I'm assuming.
Or I want to believe that
he was happy about it.
After NIFT, I did
work in Hyderabad
for a couple of years in
retail, and also in Bangalore,
when I was invited
by NIFT again.
I think my old institute
where I studied,
they were very fond of me.
They always called
me back to teach.
So I came back to NIFT to teach
as a guest faculty, teaching
my favorite subject,
print design.
And that's when, when I was
actually with my students
is when--
you know that little
urge of, I think
I want to study a little more.
And at that point, you
had time on your side.
When I say time, age.
So I eventually did
my second master's.
I did my MA Fashion in Italy--
Milan.
I was 29 then, when
I went to Milan,
and I think Milan changed
me as a person totally.
I have to talk about all this--
this journey from dentistry
to going to NIFT, Hyderabad,
and then of course, to Italy--
Milan-- Europe.
Because I think it's
very, very important
for all of us to travel--
travel alone to
discover yourself.
When you are in a
foreign land by yourself,
that is when you actually
realize what you are.
I'm not saying that you can't
do that living in your country,
but then I think what
does meditation to do you?
Right?
Same thing happens
when you travel.
And I was a very, very
short-tempered person
when I was here,
back then in college.
I would like-- probably,
also, I was carrying too much
of a baggage from
a certain time.
But for me, it was
also about running away
from a lot of
things from my past.
So I think reaching Milan and
starting life fresh from then--
because it was a new
surrounding for me--
starting fresh.
New people around.
So it was about
a lot of chapters
which you left
behind in your life.
You didn't-- you want to just
dig them and don't show them
to anybody.
I remember this one time when
my friend in Milan asked me,
Ganesh, do you ever get angry?
I just love when she asked me
that, because I remember back
in NIFT, everybody was so
scared to come and even
talk to me, because I
was so short-tempered.
But when I went to
Milan, that whole change.
I knew that, yes, I'm
liking this phase of mine
where you're
accepting everything
that way everything is, and you
know, you have the patience.
You are accepting.
I think it was
around the same time
when I actually
accepted myself also--
when today, I say that I am gay.
After coming back from Milan--
why did I come back from Milan?
Though I knew that there was--
I would have probably lived--
when I say live,
I literally mean
I could breathe easily
without thinking or caring
about what one
would think of me,
or what anybody would judge if
what I wear, or what I speak,
or whom I'm looking at.
So-- but then I think at
that point in my life,
my priorities were
very different.
There's a lot of
ambition, you know.
When you finish college,
there's that zeal
to do something nice
about your life.
So when I came
back from Milan, it
was about starting
my own studio.
There was so much of energy
in terms of what's next?
How do I go about it,
because also coming
from a non-business family--
my mom's an art teacher,
my dad's a marketing person,
and nobody was into business.
So for me, it was a
totally new thing.
So again, after
coming back, I went
and I spent a
month in Auroville,
and just to try and figure it
out as to what do I do now?
How do I go about
planning my studio?
I come back, and of course, on
the first of September, 2007,
that I started my studio with
just a couple of machines.
Tried and contacted
my really old tailors,
and embroidery carriers.
I said, I'm starting this.
Will you come work for me?
And everybody was there.
I think they kind of
followed where I was going,
and then that one
phone call, and I said,
[INAUDIBLE] will you
come work for me?
And everybody was there.
I felt like I must have
done something good,
that today everybody wants
to come and be with you.
And that's how the journey of
my label, Ganesh Nallari, began.
It started with designing
clothes for family, friends.
And I've never really
publicized my work, like what
you see in magazines and all.
It was purely word of
mouth, and even till date,
as I complete my 10 years in
a couple of days from now,
I have never publicized my work.
It has purely being
word of mouth,
and I truly believe that is
the best way to reach out.
Today, after a lot of
social media platforms
or in other things
which are available,
I think it is an
easier way to connect
with your client, or
anybody for that matter.
But nothing like a one-on-one,
when you hear like,
oh, this person is
wearing something nice,
and you hear it is done
by some so-and-so person.
Why I'm mentioning you about my
clothing here is because when
I--
I function very
different at my studio.
It is not about a retail outlet
where you just go and pick
something which is on the shelf.
For me, it is about people.
For me, it is about dressing
you, but not forcing myself
on you.
When I say that you will
find a lot of designer pieces
in the market,
but for me, yes, I
will give you a designer
piece, but for me you
are important more than me.
Your personality has to
reflect in what you wear.
I come secondary there, and
that's what I truly believe.
Because every
individual is different,
and that should shine first.
Otherwise, everybody
would start looking
like a copy of each other.
I also say this at
this point that when
we talk about every individual
being different, yes.
There's black, gray, and white.
There is also gray, which
we always tend to forget.
So there is a man,
there's a woman,
and there's somebody in between
who has a certain preference,
right?
So I did not come
out to the world
then, when I started
in my studio.
Being very
professional at work--
you have so many people you
are meeting on a daily basis.
Fashion, yes, there
are so many women
you interact with every day.
And it was one of my
clients who had invited me
for her birthday.
I was very adamant of--
because I usually prefer
keeping it separate.
I don't like to--
I am a private person, to
a large extent, until I
let somebody in my life.
And there was this
one time when--
she was a very regular
client, and she said,
you have to come for my
birthday, and I said, OK.
And things kind of
changed from there,
because there was this
party, and of course, we
were all having a great
time, and I love to dance.
Which most Hyderabad
men don't, sadly.
And I was having a
great time dancing,
and there were three
women in front of me
and three women behind me.
We were doing this weird--
I don't know what.
But we were having a great time.
And there was so much
of comfort around.
At that point, I think one of
the husbands did not like it,
and so another
guy from the party
came and he just
whispered in my ear,
saying, dude, what
are you doing?
I said, what am I doing?
I'm having a great time.
And then he just
pulled me to the side
and he said, the
way you're dancing
with these other ladies.
I said, yeah, they're
all my friends.
So what's wrong?
He said, do you realize that
they're all married women?
I said, so?
Like, I'm having a good
time with my friends,
and they invited me.
I have a certain
comfort with them,
and I'm having a great time.
At that point, I think I just
told that guy, you know what?
Relax.
I'm gay.
And that was it.
I didn't even have to try coming
out to anybody, or do anything.
He did the job for me.
I was like, thank you.
I think it made my life
so much more easier.
So he took care of
my PR in terms of--
you do my job of you
coming out for me.
[LAUGHING] So well,
that's about it.
When it came to society--
I mean, when I say society,
in terms of the people
around you, your
client, or everybody--
this is how I came
out to the world.
But I think my biggest
concern was when
I was coming out to my parents.
I still do not know if I
have come out to them or not.
But considering I am at an age
where I should've been married
and all my friends almost have
kids who are in high school
now, and it was only once
that my mom asked me if I--
that I should consider marriage.
I didn't even have
to say a word.
I just looked at her.
I used all my dance expressions,
and I just looked at her,
and I said, that's it.
And that was the first
and the last time
she actually asked
me about marriage.
So I live by myself
in Hyderabad.
My parents also live in
Hyderabad, in [INAUDIBLE]..
I visit them every
Sunday for lunch.
I am mentioning this again
because every Sunday when
I go home, there's always been
that urge of, you know what?
Today, I think I'm
going to tell them.
Just finish it, you know?
I don't want to keep them under
any hope of that, you know?
That he will get married
at some point or whatever.
I think it's always--
I always felt like it's good
to sit and talk and finish it.
But then every Sunday, I would
go thinking that OK, today I'm
going to tell them.
But I don't know.
I would just-- then
I would postpone it
for the next week,
thinking that I mean, yeah,
I had a good time.
Why again disturb this
whole peace at home?
I came, I had my lunch,
I had a nice nap.
They gave me tea, I had tea.
I played with my dog.
So let it just be.
I'll postpone it
to the next Sunday.
So it was around the
same time that I actually
started doing theater.
And in Hyderabad,
there's a theater group
which organizes short
play competitions.
And I had also worked with
the theater group previously,
and this friend of
mine, he said, Ganesh,
you should take part
in this competition.
And he was the
one who pushed me.
So when I decided to
write a story, I said,
why not write about my own self?
So that's when I did my first--
that's when I wrote
my first play.
I also directed in it.
Of course, I had to act in it.
So I thought, let me
write about me and my mom.
And I used stage as a platform
to tell my story to the world--
more to my parents.
So I just changed a little about
the designer being a dancer.
How he becomes the famous
dancer, and the story
is about two dancers,
the mother and the son,
and how the mother faces a
lot of challenges in her life.
How she gives up her
passion for dance,
but she secretly teaches
the son dance, and--
but when it actually
comes to when
the mother questions the son
about marriage, he does not--
he doesn't have words,
because he's so frightened.
He's terrified.
He's just not able
to tell it to her.
So at that point, he
dances, and he tells his mom
about what-- who he is.
So when I wrote the script,
and I was discussing it with
my co-actor, the lady who
played my mother's role,
and also with my friend who
was doing the lighting for me,
I remember he mentioning
that [INAUDIBLE] dance--
to me, it's a
[INAUDIBLE] who will
understand what you're doing?
I said, if nobody
understands what I did,
that means I failed as a
dancer, I failed as a writer,
as an actor.
I failed in communicating,
but forget about anything
but telling what I had
to tell my parents.
I said, no.
I'm going to do the same
thing in the climax,
and that is going
to be the ending.
And so we qualified
in the prelims,
and we reached the finals.
And the big day, and I remember
the last scene happening.
There was pin-drop silence.
It's a very emotional,
very heavy scene--
the last scene.
And I could see me and
my co-actor of course,
me getting emotional is
understood because I'm telling
my story, but then I remember
the girl who played my mom--
I could hear her crying.
It's so quiet, and I
could hear her cry.
That-- it echoed
in the auditorium.
And the lights were
off, and we both
were still hugging and crying.
Actually, truly, somebody had
to come and say, hon, time up.
Please go.
We were like, oh, OK.
And of course, we
won [INAUDIBLE]..
[INAUDIBLE] won the competition.
We were second, because it was
a very unconventional story.
I was glad that we won,
not just because it
was important about winning
the competition, but about
the audience accepting us.
When I say us, I mean
the LGBT community.
At that point, I
realized it was not
about me just talking
about my life,
but then there must have been so
many people in the audience who
related to it.
Who were there to accept me,
and people like me there.
So when I finished the
play, after getting
that trophy and
just walked down,
and I was still unsure about
whether my parents understood
or no.
So I-- somebody--
this girl who came
and who was congratulating me.
What a powerful scene,
Ganesh-- the last one.
I said, thank you.
And somebody tapped
me from the back,
and she was telling
to this person--
this girl was standing in
front of me, saying that,
but that is all true.
And I just turned back.
It was my mom.
I was like, OK.
She got the message.
So that's how I came
out to my parents.
It was very interesting,
but it has always
been that way, that be it
coming out as who I am,
or in every
situation, I've always
used some way or
the other of art
being centric towards my life.
It was around the same
time in 2009 that I--
it just happened that
one of my family members
also passed away,
and it also happens
that this person was the one
who abused me all my life.
All my life in the sense--
my whole childhood.
So I wasn't talking to
him for very, very long.
Yeah, it was a guy.
I wasn't talking to
him for very long
and everybody knew in the family
that I really didn't get along
very well with him.
So when he passed
away that day, I
think I was the one
who cried the most.
Because I did not know if I have
to mourn the death of a family
member or celebrate a chapter,
which was over in my life.
So I just happened to--
I came back home, and I was
chatting with a friend of mine
who happens to be a filmmaker.
And I told him that
this is what happened,
and I just came back
from the funeral.
And he said, Ganesh, will
you write the story for me?
I said no.
I will share important
parts of my life
with you, but I don't
want to dig back and talk
about anything--
what had happened.
And eventually,
the film was made.
The film is called "I Am."
They're four short stories
directed by Onir, and "I Am,"
"Abhimanyu" is based on mine,
and another friend, Harish
Iyer, from Bombay.
So it's an inspiration,
but it's an autobiography.
There are parts of
the scenes where
he has picked from my
life and Harish's life,
and the movie's made.
"I Am" eventually won the
National Award in 2012,
and I am again
talking about my abuse
here because for a long
time, I think I was blaming
my abuse for my sexuality.
Because-- because it's an age
when you have your crushes.
You see your friends
around who go
on Valentine's Day with
a rose, and here you're
sitting in one corner
trying to figure out what's
happening around, you know?
Dealing with your own abuse--
with your sexuality.
I just pretended that
even I was straight.
I would just randomly buy a
rose and go give a girl whom--
I didn't even go
on real [INAUDIBLE]
just to make a point
that, oh, he did this,
so even I should be doing it.
Today when I look--
I think back of all the
silly things which I did,
and trying to be
somebody else, just
because my other friends, other
guys in the class were doing.
But then there was such
a pure relationship
with all the friends I had,
like be it a guy or a girl,
you know?
There was no--
there is intimacy.
You know, when you
talk about intimacy,
you also have to realize
that there are two
different kinds of intimacy.
There is a physical
intimacy, and then there's
also an emotional connect
you have with a individual.
But all my emotional connects
have been only with women.
Yes, because I also say only
with women, because today,
I worry that if I have--
or with whoever I have an
emotional connect with a guy--
the world looks
at that other boy,
also thinking that he's gay.
That has become my
biggest challenge today--
to have good guy friends.
You go to a party,
everybody's clicking pictures.
You have three women
and you take a picture.
Everybody is fine with that.
One post with that
boy on Facebook
or anywhere on social media,
next question involved-- so,
are you dating him?
I'm like, give me a break.
He's a straight guy.
You know, you make
that other person
conscious about not
taking a picture with you.
So what I'm trying
to tell you here
is it hasn't been tough because
you're also dealing with abuse,
and you're also dealing with
discovering your own self.
The last time I actually
was felt by somebody
was when my abuse--
when the last time
the abuse happened.
But for the longest time, I
almost lived like an asexual,
because for me, it
was something bad.
It was something which I
did not want in my life,
because you are looked at--
your body is looked
at as an object.
So I really had trust issues.
I found that comfort
around women,
but I would never
go close to a boy.
Also I think you
come from a time
when people did not even know
what a gay or a lesbian is.
I'm talking what the
previous generation.
Not now.
Like how openly
we talk about it.
So even I did not know what
was going on, honestly.
We have so many apps, and
it's so much more easier
to connect with the
community today.
But I'm talking about a
time, like a few years back--
not too--
I'm not very old.
Just a couple of years back,
that even to find somebody
to just talk about how
you feel was so difficult.
And so I think over a
period of time, I had to--
I'd worked on
myself in many ways.
Like I said, as I
mentioned about dentistry
to design, this whole
journey to where I am today--
and to reach a state of mind
where you accept yourself
for what it is without worrying
about who is judging you.
So what is most important
is, I'm not going to ask--
I'm not going to
question any of you
all here whether you have
come out of the closet.
Do we need a
heterosexual to come out
of the closet to prove that
he's heterosexual, and say
that he likes women?
So at that point, I feel
everybody's sexual preference
is their personal business.
I will come out to people whom
I think are important to me.
I do not even care about what
the third, fourth person is
going to think about me.
So coming out is never about
coming out for the society.
Coming out is always
for you, because if you
feel it is important that you
come out and you feel lighter,
you will realize that.
How long can you live
in denial, you know?
There might be a lot of cases
where people are married
and living a dual life,
cheating on partners,
but they still know that
there is something--
that they are doing
something wrong,
because they haven't
totally come face-to-face
with reality with themselves.
Again, like I
said, I do not want
to judge who's done
that, because I think
whoever is living
a particular life
is living a particular life.
Only they know what they are
going through in their life.
But as far as I'm
concerned, I'm talking
in specific about
marriage because I
think some people still
expect-- my relatives expect
that I should get married.
Even when I'm so
openly gay, some people
ask questions like--
like I remember this
last time when--
I usually don't go
to family gatherings,
only to avoid this--
and as soon as I
went, one of my aunt's
asked me, so, Ganesh, when
are you getting married?
She just said it so loud.
I was so embarrassed.
I just-- I want to just
tell it to her, saying, oh,
just find me a cute
boy and I'm ready.
I with there was an
arranged marriage even
for the LGBT
community, you know?
It would just make life
so much more easier.
And I just looked at
my mom, and I said,
this is the reason why I don't
want to come to such places.
And she's like, OK.
Calm down.
So coming out is
always for yourself,
and life always gives
us many chances.
It's only for us to look
forward for new beginnings.
And I think what you do is
everything is in your hands.
You create your opportunities.
I truly believe that you have
to create your opportunities.
You create your moments,
your situations.
There's confusion.
It's all right.
I think confusion
gives you choices.
But you can design your life.
People can help you or support
you, but it's all up to you
what you want to do.
So whether you want
to come out and face--
and live an honest
life, or suffer within,
it's totally your call.
But what is most important is
just being honest to yourself.
Yeah.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]